preparing students and teachers for a
worst-case situation is becoming more
commonplace at schools across the
country but the emergency preparation
for an active shooting at a school in
Indiana took a disturbing turn this week
and it's raising questions about the
program dean reynolds has the story
at the middle lawn Elementary School in
Monticello Indiana they take active
shooter drills very seriously we want to
try to put the teachers under stress
under under a traumatic situation
basically so they know how their bodies
are gonna react White County deputy
sheriff David Roth was at the last drill
in January teaching the teachers not to
be victims so the school requested this
yes they did did the people who
requested it understand what it entailed
yes what it entailed was one drill with
teachers lined up in an empty classroom
and shot in the back by a deputy with an
airsoft gun like this one which fires
small plastic pellets would you say it's
painful no I've been salt with them
numerous times they're not painful we
spoke to a targeted teacher who
complained but didn't want to be
identified
did it hurt it hurt quite a bit I had a
welt and another spot drew blood and
scabbed over and they hurt consistently
for about a week and half at least 42
states now require schools to conduct
safety or security drills and some
people are injured unintentionally but
this struck dan Holub of the Indiana
State Teachers Association as excessive
the teachers are there they don't know
this is coming and all of a sudden
they're being asked to turn around and
they're shot at it's it's just craziness
these teachers they're our friends
the sheriff has now decided to suspend
the shooting drills indefinitely while
the program is modified I hate the fact
that we even have to train teachers for
this scenario but these days it's an
all-too-familiar one for CBS this
morning Saturday Dean Reynolds
Monticello Indiana not clear why they
have to actually be shot with pellets
yeah not clear not clear as I say
they're modifying the program right it
makes sense to prepare teachers for how
to react
but not once they've been shot it's too
late at that point we'll see what
happens